desafío de kiev para quedarse con
la tendencia de los varios o escaneo de misiles
impactado contra la cabeza de un centro urbano
desde la capital de Kenia durante un
visita del secretario general de la nación
sobre los hidratos de antonio guterres de estados unidos
del ataque pero serio de la retirada
del demasiado ruso en la zona norte e
del eje sur iii semana es
tommaso se preocupa precisamente del poeta
del encuentro que guti fue el manto con
el presidente de rusia vladimir putin
lo tomó ukrania nathan viene
informó otros ataques a corridos e
la región a ecos y ven en particular
está allá arriba en el fa steve i che adrian
en rodajas es la infraestructura de la zona de edad
al otro lado en odessa y en el sur
son una expresión de lo que
el ejército ucraniano intercepta un
misil rumbo a asia y sta
ubicaciones mientras que lejos koven elegido
don demos stato oi tambien se han
continuar pro señor diferente si explosión
si en un momento en que edad usas
que la segunda pero si importante ye
Ucrania y se siente particularmente
también afectó el conflicto bélico